hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to two yandere
simulator okay so this game has been
requested for a long time now and I'm
starting to get an idea why you play as
a yandere one of those Japanese super
obsessed with SEM PI's thankfully I
don't think I have any Yonder rows so I
should be fine
and what we're gonna be doing deserve it
why can't I do a new game why is it only
resume game I haven't played this before
alright here we go cool we're gonna play
yandere simulator 6:00 p.m. deadline is
that the deadline from which I need to
kill everybody or is that when I need to
declare my love to my senpai notice
right okay little weird change why why
would I need that why oh hey everyone
knows that if a girl wears white panties
she must be a pure and innocent angel
son something tells me I'm not whoa this
seems weird is this necessary to the
game is this pertinent information from
my everyday life I get with pink sure
why not
alright equipped I did a whole lot of
nothing what else am I gonna do about
this hello
senpai shrine Oh toothbrush I stole from
Sam Pie's home brushing my teeth with
this is a wonderful feeling a bandage
this empire through some of his
delicious blood is still on it
Annapolis Empire took a bite of the
teeth marks is so much fun oh wow what's
in my basement what's in my basement
oh good nothing I was a little concerned
for a second there is this where I shock
everybody might as well go to school all
right here we go hi hello ah good this
is a debug build for testing this is not
an official demo okay so that was the
declaration at the beginning of this
game
that this game is like only 5% done so
there's not much here hi how's it going
hello
oh is that senpai senpai don't notice me
notice me
hello what do you do oh you're looking
at your phone hello hi how's it going
what do I do
I recognize that student here's some
information what who am i sending this
to you either ASSA don't mind me I'm not
being weird screw you something about
you look the same you got the hair of
that one Japanese Idol that's not a real
person
are you my senpai huh hey you hold still
I need to ask something you have such
beautiful eyes sure don't mind why stare
at your vulnerable place NIT nape of
your neck I got a clear shot of your
face what do you want from me how about
this for clear where's my senpai senpai
senpai oh god I'm so beautiful oh he's
so dreamy oh God
sorry Sam PI I just love the taste I
just want to lick your teeth is that
weird
probably not apparently I can't approach
senpai look at me don't be a weirdo you
don't need any pictures of myself I why
not
how dare you my point is so important
you look good you look great today what
with your matching hair and eyeballs I
know I'm so nice hard look at me I'm the
greatest you too
you look so good I'm building reputation
with everybody before I go on my
murderous rampage of course I won't have
it anytime soon whoa what's with your
boobs that's probably the rude thing to
say to a person but I'm really I'm
concerned
with the hair and the boobs situation it
just seems a little odd to me
hello gaggle of friends I am a normal
girl look at me look at me look at me
look at me and weep it how much more yes
salute me I guess okay look how much
more prettier I am are than you
I'm flying into all of your weak
vulnerable emotions oh you look lovely
got you boobs McKenzie I can't even come
with you I'll apologize for insulting
your boobs sorry
excuse me my senpai go poured my senpai
go hello oh this is glowy circle go to
class that seems important hey I done
did learn Oh
Maybelline to kill your victims more
efficiently resulting in less blood this
little bizarre but at least I'm learning
too bad no lunch for me oh no I could
have eaten lunch with my senpai oh I
guess I'm done where's my sand pie boy
BRR not been messing with my senpai
boobs McKenzie you yeah it's mine I'll
murder you I shall murder you all your
hair would look great on my wall Thanks
is this
oh okay I'm just uh practicing for later
for cleaning up the blood I don't know
what you're thinking of how's this I
can't I can't drop this excuse me excuse
me I'm just gonna sweep the cras over
here huh boy this ground dirty do I get
extra credit whatever the hell name you
are okay I don't I don't need these now
do I
it would be bad to have those houses I'm
gonna go home now I'm gonna go home I
can't go home I'm stuck in sweep mode
I'm stuck in perpetual sweep mode I just
want to go home
damn and how do I drop some oh okay that
did that did the thing stealth mode
yandere chan stands near the school gate
and waits for senpai to leave school
finally senpai eggs as the school yawn
Terri Chan's heart skips a beat when she
sees him young daddy Chan leaves school
and watches senpai walk home once he is
safely home yandere chan returns to her
own home yandere chin goes to sleep and
dreams of sampai because she can control
her dreams knows exactly what she wants
to dream about it old
oh you so beautiful oh look at the way
the rose petals and pie and pie is that
yosef i locked on target
Oh Georgia I'm gonna love you Oh
hmm oh you're so pretty
look at you oh my god this isn't weird
at all look at all those jealous girls
jealous of me being this close to you it
is so pretty no one shall ever do you
bruh me you like me oh god chuckles
yikes
nothing you saw nothing nothing at all
compliment you look great today you're
welcome I don't know how limited the
functionality this demo actually is so I
don't know if there's a point to me
actually trying to befriend everybody
just yet
I don't even know when this game was
gonna be fully man I am emotional Tron
92 I shall send my emotions do you
standing in your gossip circles hey I
shall join for the lunching I can't let
simple I notice me I can't let him pay
notice me do these think I'm weird oh I
hope he doesn't let me just get a sneaky
shot straight in his front view him
he'll never suspect a thing
got it shaved and now I'm out of here
yes the secret plan was a complete
success I know exactly what I'm doing in
this endeavor of love you want me
everybody is Empire out of my view whoa
that was a close one
pissed me off to my educational
faculties oh boy the gossip circle oh
yeah here in just a moment everybody I
wasn't just seeing Sam bye what are
y'all talking about
I don't know what the deadlines means is
that like the deadline for my love to be
declared to him because if not by then
then it's all going to be over who
follow me follow me I indeed want you
disease this ha whoa okay whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's just her hair dye she put too
much in you didn't see anything you
weird standing person jump dump the body
look I get to change my clothes great
and then I get to carry this I get to
put it dip it in the pocket then I get
to come out from school there's a little
janitorial duties
it's like viscera cleanup detail all
over again it's at this time I made this
no one will ever know and just like that
[Music]
my master plan is unfolding before me
new teacher I still don't know how to
get senpai affections I just want him to
love me why does he not love ya
narration
yeah yandere yon dear the school's
faculty members inform the students that
a murder has taken place on school
grounds hmm the faculty instruct all
students to remain at school and
cooperate with the police to catch the
killer police arrive to school and begin
their investigation the Caligula the
police quickly discovered a corpse on
school grounds and we're also able to
locate a weapon that it beams you for
murder
wait a minute no huh no no no but I
burned the body oh I didn't burn the
Bayeux I just dumped it oh no my heart
[Music]
oh snap I'll save apperently William
arrow wire every wind sent wise
affections will never suffer this
rampage will send notice me find out
next on yonder
[Music]